ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show uh we have uh coming up later
in the broadcast an Insider from svb
Silicon Valley Bank who calls into the
show and discusses the chaos that's
happening they have been taken over by
the federal government he said there's
ads now for svb saying Silicon Valley
Bank is the safest place uh to put your
money
um but we're looking at potentially
um you know they're trying to find a
buyer for svb they're trying to find a
buyer it's a it's a very woke bank and
you know it's diverse and inclusive and
fun and sexy and you know gender is a
construct and everything it's a fun kind
of Silicon Valley Bank that's what they
do and I'm not that's not the reason it
collapsed I'm not I'm not going on some
reaction or anything here I'm just
saying it's part of the vibe it's a Vibe
Silicon Valley Bank was a Vibe and they
tried to get the Saudis to buy it and
the Saudis have a little decidedly
different vibe than that but I think
nothing would make more sense than
having the Saudis come in and whip
Silicon Valley Bank into shape watching
an analyst at Silicon Valley Bank
explain the concept of non-binary to
Mohammed bin Salman is something I would
like to see that's something I would
like to see members of the Saudi
Sovereign wealth fund sitting there with
Silicon Valley bank and going through
just the office policies
you know the human resources policies at
the bank who can say what to whom I
think that's a great idea in fact if
this
if this whole Bank collapse which people
are debating whether it's going to be a
massive collapse I'm reading things that
say this is Lehman Brothers credit Swiss
is going down even though they got a 52
billion dollar loan from the Central
Bank of Switzerland they're still done
they're looking at scenarios for the
bank over the weekend people are going
this is a similar thing that happened to
Lehman Monday is going to be Black
Monday credit Swiss is going to go first
national is going to go credit Swiss is
a trillion First National although the
regional Banks it'll take down with it
is a trillion we're looking at massive
runs on the bank I believe I believe a
crazy amount of money was taken out of
JP Morgan because these are Bank runs
people are going we want our money
and maybe Peter Thiel caused this run at
svb we don't know
it's possible but people the bank's been
in solvent for a while and Peter chill
goes I gotta get my [__] money out of
there and people start you know going
well you know what Peter till took his
money out maybe I'll take my money out
but these are kind of these
old-fashioned Bank runs
um and people don't really know how bad
they're gonna get and if this is going
to be systemic and spread but
um what excites me potentially about
this is seeing Middle Eastern
dictatorships take over Progressive Bay
Area lenders in America just that
because it's a fun sitcom
it's an actual fun sitcom to see Saudi
Nationals going into Silicon Valley Bank
and dealing with the people that work
there it's an actual if that's what
comes out of this we're the Middle
Eastern you know ultra-conservative
religious Saudi people have to go in and
run this woke American Northern NorCal
Northern California company is this not
gonna be a hoot that to me could be a
lot of fun now obviously people are
saying that's best case because nobody
wants to buy svb the Saudis don't want
to buy it
because it's just you know it's got a
bunch of shitty startup ideas and a
bunch of people are walking around with
blue hair on the Saudis go we're not
into that we want Live Nation that makes
the money we get it we understand it put
Billy eilish on the stage she cuts
herself the kids pay the money not this
[__] game of like no you have no idea
how many great ideas we have tell them
about your idea tell them about your
idea it's that's what it is silicon van
gave every [__] guy at Stanford with
a hoodie four hundred thousand dollars
to come up with anything they wanted and
where are where is the new Uber where
are these things they don't exist
because tack like everything else is
fake there's a few good ideas like
movies or music there's a few good ideas
many of them happen by accident most of
the good ideas in Tech are people that
are like I would like to [__] women I
mean this is what happens they Facebook
Zuckerberg the entire Facebook all of
meta which is now a nightmare because
people are leaving this horrible world
he created on the on the metaverse I
don't know who's left in the metaverse
it's like pedophiles that are like what
is this let's go back to the dark web
this is horrible but all meta was was
Mark Zuckerberg trying to get laid
you know all a lot of these advancements
in Tech come because you have people
that are brilliant but maybe they're on
the Spectrum maybe they're not the most
socially capable people and they they
actually have these you know brilliant
ideas and some of those ideas end up
enriching our quality of life and many
of them don't right many of them have
made our quality of life kind of worse
more lonely more isolating and uh you
know but Silicon Valley Bank they're the
big startup Bank they're the bank that
hands money to all these [__]
and goes just run with it do what you
you know do what you want to do
and uh nobody's buying that right now
like nobody they haven't found a buyer
it's not to say that they won't but they
haven't found a buyer because you know
it's not it's it's like you know people
are going that's not a sure thing it's
the opposite of a sure thing you have
all this entrepreneurial Talent
supposedly you have all these great
ideas for companies maybe but what you
don't have is a sure fire thing that's
where the Saudis commit by Live Nation
no problem in the middle of the pandemic
they're like yeah we know hey as soon as
the pandemic's over people are gonna go
out they're gonna go to concerts they're
gonna go to comedy shows like the ones
I'm doing at the Chicago Theater uh on
June 9th and the Masonic in San
Francisco on June 21st Tim
dilloncomedy.com get all your tickets to
everything I'm at Milwaukee at the Pabst
Theater second show we edited at the
Pantages Theater in Tacoma whatever it's
not a commercial for myself what I'm
saying is that timetablecomedy.com what
I'm saying is that Live Nation probably
is a better it was a better it's more
you can understand it the Saudis
understand it they go we like live
things usually it's we get to hand but
we understand what a live thing is we
understand Live Events usually we're
beheading women we're burning gay people
at the stake but it's live they like
live they got it this [__] is like you
know they don't know what the [__]
going on so they understand yes we put a
bunch of people in a room and we go and
get to thieves and we cut the hand off
the thief and everybody cheers and we go
oh it's not quite like that it's more
like Drake and I spies in a big field
but the Saudis understand that they
understand what life is I wouldn't buy
Silicon Valley Bank I don't know what it
I don't know what's happened I don't
know who you got do you have the next
Mark Zuckerberg you have the next
Elizabeth Holmes we don't know but what
we're excited about is Tech now becoming
the new manufacturing where it's taken
over other people do it in other
countries and the tech people we force
them to live the same way that we have
forced generations of people in
manufacturing to live they live in Rust
Belt states they live in the middle of
the country we ship their jobs overseas
and they get addicted to opioids we
watch their lives hollow out we watch
their faces hollow out like a zenpick
William you know it gets because the
example gets really you start to see it
now in California gets really hard and
it's like a fish and they get really
hard kind of like that Scream painting
but we watch the faces because if you go
to some of these play you know read meth
land which is a great book all of these
people their their faces hollow out and
they have blue under their eyes and they
live in these these horrific uh
conditions in these towns uh with water
that's not good and food deserts where
they can't get this salad right we we
are we are optimistic
that many of the hopefully the tech
people will meet that same fate that
it's only fair right it's only fair that
eventually tech people have to live in
that I don't want to say a place because
people are going to get offended by
whatever I say right if I'm I'm gonna
use a a town as an example or
um
something that is grotesque and you know
but but let's just say uh let's just say
a town uh somewhere uh where it is not
nice out huh it's not nice and maybe
it's hot and sticky and there's you know
there's just it's a town that has seen
better days you know will Austin one day
look like Flint Michigan
oh
I mean will Austin one day look you know
because we go when I go on the road I go
we drive through these things we drive
through Flint Michigan we drive through
these old you know rust belt or you know
all of these different states that at
one time were standards of manufacturing
you know up in I believe I did a theater
up in Rochester New York and you know
there was a guy standing next to me I
believe it was Rochester might have been
Schenectady but I believe it was
Rochester and I was staying at the
theater was by the Kodak what used to be
the Kodak Factory people used to take
photos and then Kodak obviously was the
film and this was big up until digital
cameras and phones and now the Kodak
Factory tests people's blood
they do blood tests
I think they test for drugs or maybe
they test for
cancers I don't know but that's what it
is now the Kodak Factory has become a
blood testing facility I believe up
there in Upstate New York so I'd go to
places like this to perform and they
were a great audience and and we you
know we were we're grateful to everyone
it comes out to see comedy but it is it
is just my sincere hope it's a little
thing that I I like I love hope and to
me one day if Austin Texas
is
instead of a tech Hub just a thing where
like people walk around
and the only thing that's left is the
mothership comedy club The Joe Rogan
Comedy Club and I somehow survived
despite you know my smoking and the
weight and everything I somehow survive
and I'm in my 70s or 60s and I'm there
and and I'm like we have the busts of
Ron White and Roseanne that are long
gone but we just we've stuffed them you
know we've done we've done like uh what
do they call that Taxidermy we've
Taxidermy our favorite uh Comedians and
I'm up there being like Oh Austin used
to be a real Tech Hub looking at it now
and it's just the tech people meet the
same fate as the manufacturing sector
there's something so great about because
it's it's it's great now in Austin
everybody's excited and everybody's a
new glass buildings and they're buying
houses in the Westlake Hills that look
just like L.A except you know it's
there's a there's a disgusting
vomit-colored River whatever is fine
I've I've gone I've I've done that well
repeatedly and you know whatever I I
actually like Austin a little more now
than I did but just it's a perfect
example in San Francisco see San
Francisco it's not even fun San
Francisco's already a hellscape it's
already where what it's going to be
there's something about this if the tech
thing is so good for Humanity why is
everywhere that the tech things going on
looks like the apocalypse
why is that why if this Tech thing is
just such a universal good is San
Francisco the area that Tech has been
concentrated in for years
literally an insane Healthcare it's very
interesting I was passing I was in
Austin for South by for the opening of
Jones club which is a lot of fun if
you're down there go grab tickets
um when I saw this little homeless
encampment in Austin and then there's
something right next to it there was a
poster that says the rise of virtual
communities and there was a poster and
there's this guy you know sitting there
on a on a mattress in the middle of you
know the the sidewalk and on the chain
link fence next to him there was a
poster that says the rise of virtual
communities it's very interesting that
this seems to go hand in hand the the
attack seems to go hand in hand with the
decay of these Urban centers because
tech people usually set up shop on the
outside they get all the real estate it
on the outside of these cities they prop
it up it becomes very expensive but the
cities themselves and maybe some of the
poor suburbs on the outside of the
Cities don't do well so I am not saying
that I want to see all of these tech
people living like the old manufacturing
people
Oxycontin addicts sitting in a table
eating store brand ketchup on White
Bread while their children run around in
the yard and play with the gun I'm not
saying I want that I'm saying it might
be fun it might be fun to see people who
used to work in Tech wearing flannel
shirts not ironically because they have
nothing else that might be good seeing
people that used to work in a fun Tech
environment where everybody's in hoodies
and nobody had to wear suits and it was
so comfortable to ruin the world it
might be fun to see those people deal
with crippling generational poverty and
addiction
it may not be it might I don't know I'm
just saying it might be fun to see that
be smart don't start kick the habit pull
it out before it puts you out all
phrases we've heard a hundred times yet
we still continue that bad habits any
bad habit that's hard
um you know our sponsor fume is on a
mission to accelerate Humanity's breakup
from the bad happens to consume too many
of us fume is a natural diffusive device
that uses uh plants and Behavioral
Science to help you trade out your
negative habit for positive one fume is
not a vape it is a non-electric device
designed to transform your negative
habits instead of PODS filled with
potentially harmful chemicals like a
vape fume uses cores infused with plants
like peppermint and cinnamon for
delicious natural flavors with an
adjustable airflow dial and a magnetic
uh end cap your fingers will always have
something to do
talk about oh the look and the feel and
the taste of fume your personal
experience testimony oh I love fume
everyone loves fume everyone I know
loves you my family loves fume everybody
loves fume it's the easiest way to stop
a bad hat and switch to a the easiest
way to stop a bad habit is switch to a
positive one and fume is designed
perfectly to do just that it's fumes
goal to make switching easy and even
enjoyable they have thousands of five
star reviews from people just like you
who've successfully switched and other
Solutions just didn't work head to
trifum.com and use code Tim Tim to save
10 trifum.com and he was code Tim Tim to
save 10 when you get the journey pack
today the journey pack comes with three
unique flavors a new version two fume to
help kick-start your positive habits try
fum.com use code Tim 10 off but I'm not
I don't like this
I don't like this Bank collapse and I
and because I have a little bit of money
now so what I want the poor to do if
this happens behave please
because I know the poor and they are
good people but they will start
and what we're asking you to do
please is just watch the Netflix
if they won't let you get the money out
of your account just watch the goddamn
Netflix
don't go out into the street and try to
kill me when I'm in my Bentley which is
from 2018.
it's not even new it's not even new
don't pull me out of that and kill me
because you have issues what you have to
do is watch the Netflix if it all goes
big because they have how how many
programs do they have on that it's
unending how many programs you have on
Netflix you will get food we will give
you food calm down you're gonna get food
it'll be bugs but bugs are good they're
crunchy like cookies
what's on Netflix there are 36 000 hours
to go through sit and watch Netflix
don't take to the streets
please behave
behave
please God it's perfect weather for this
too I wish this was the dead of Summer
I wish this was the dead of Summer this
is perfect Springtime weather for a
fight this is like the Arab Spring we
could have it in America please be Eve
just relax
don't kill me kill the others they have
more
they have more I'm telling you they have
more I'll show you where they live
behave watch the Netflix eat the can of
pasta you get
we will give you a can of pasta eat it
share it with the children
and pray get God again time for God
can of Pasta Plus God equals good life
killing me not nice
that's not right I'm in this Blended but
we're over this right we know they're
rapists but they make free acts get
someone else to make three acts I'll
throw it out
I'm telling you right now just please
behave don't go nuts out there I know
they're gonna go nuts I can feel it this
is what's gonna happen they're gonna
Monday they're gonna go to the ATM and
his money's not gonna come out and they
are going to it's gonna be bad
but I would like you at that moment when
the money doesn't come out of the ATM I
want you to go huh
go back to your home
because we are sending care packages
they will be sent to you the government
will provide for you you will get a can
of pasta you will get a bag of cake
a bag of sugar cake for the kids
now this is my this could be my last
plea it might be my last book I didn't
know I'd be rich I'm 38 years old I had
no money my whole life I was a fat
failure my whole life from when I was
[__] nine till now I only have a
little bit of money now a little bit of
money now and it's not even enough money
it's a it's enough money to take a 22
year old out to dinner and go here's
salmon oh there's your penis that's not
even a lot of it's a little bit of money
please don't kill me when you see me in
Beverly Hills stay out of Beverly Hills
please please stay out of Beverly Hills
it's not right
I made money in a few years the the
and now I'm the Adam
hate me it's not my fault
it's not my fault these glasses are
these are worth maybe eight eight
hundred thousand dollars
I'm kidding they were 1100 I know it's
disgusting I know it's your rent I know
it's your rent I don't know what to do
for you I'm sorry I believe you should
have health care I've always said that
in a clinic that's separate from me
because they're like overcrowding I
don't want to smell you and see your
problems I'm just saying when this
happens on Monday and can you please
relax a little bit and behave
that's all I'm asking I'm just asking it
because I just have money for the last
couple of years that's it so long I was
one of you at one point waiting for the
can of pasta in my hovel thinking of
eating my fam I understand that
but I don't listen I just you know I got
a middle of money on the internet it's
not a big deal so I just want everyone
to behave and relax because I God I
think it's coming and I just don't it's
not fair Now give me a couple of years
please
Christ almighty enough bring up some
articles is this is this even gonna
happen maybe I'm overstating it God I
hope I am
why don't we come up with people to kill
so but so that it's not me we can get
people that really deserve people that
have so much more money than me and I
will help you how many how many people
took their money out of Chase
how many people took their money out of
Chase that's always a good indicator
because chases they you know Jamie
Diamond says it's a vault and what he
means by that is it's a vault of all the
Epstein tapes but it it's still a vault
and uh but people are saying go to that
guy Guantanamo Bay on Twitter he's he's
great he just tweets about Marxism and
911 all day but it's fun you know I like
someone that commits I like a theme and
um he really does he just does deep
Dives on CIA figures that were involved
in in 911 but he's he's posing these
really interesting articles about the
banking class and Peter Schiff I mean
God is Peter Schiff he's probably got a
24-hour erection he's been predicting
this collapse for years and it's finally
here the banks are going to evaporate
it's a liquidity crisis the FED cannot
lower the interest rates to zero it
would you know it's all over now and all
I'm asking on behalf of people that have
made money in the last three years is
that you remember that there are people
that have had money for a very very very
very very very long time kill them
that's all I'm asking
if you I I will help you I will help you
do you want to start a podcast this is a
good time to start a podcast you can do
it I will help you so I'm just saying
don't kill me I know that it feels like
the right thing to do and I in your
shoes might kill me too but there's a
lot of good things coming your way if
you behave can of pasta open it mmm
yummy time a bag of cake it won't be a
cake it'll be cake cake bits we'll call
them cake comes it's just easier to
deliver and you can put your hand in it
and it'll be like coffee Crumbs from a
crumb cake but with Funfetti sprinkles
then you could just you'd throw it at
the kids and the kids are going nuts
with the Funfetti it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be okay we're gonna give you
a smoothie you're gonna get a smoothie
for your bones strong but and you're
gonna be allowed out of the house for
for a good amount of time to get the
exercise but what we can't have is
violent mobs in the street asking for my
Bentley from 2018. it's not going to
help you it's from 2018. it's not even
that good
um so that that's my whole thing my
whole thing is like
um you know I just I just want everyone
to behave that's all that's all I'm
asking for you can get mad at me you can
get offended I'm just saying I've only
had money for a couple of years I used
to hang out in these really poor places
where I would do drugs when I was a
child and people would do crazy heinous
things and I you know that was the
majority of my life I was a junkie from
when I was 12 or 13 years old till 25
just drugs alcohol you know and then
from 25 to 35 it was basically just
stand-up comedy and working and then
from you know 35 to 38 which is what I
am now we've made a little bit of money
but that's certainly I am certainly not
the person to kill in this situation
there are like Chelsea Handler Chelsea
Handler has more money than me she has a
lot more money than me I'm not saying
kill her but I'm saying if there's a
this is a hierarchy everybody right now
is doing e-commerce this made me the
only way to survive but you need to
worry about origination
designing your product making sure it's
marketed effectively you don't need to
worry about the back orders you don't
need to worry about shipping ship
station is the way to do it it efforts
effortlessly integrates everywhere you
sell online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and more manage every order from
one simple dashboard automate routine
shipping tasks print shipping labels
easily compare rates and delivery times
to optimize every shipment and automate
delivery notifications so basically the
back office is run completely for you
and you're worried about what you should
be worrying about coming up with great
products figuring them out finding them
and getting them to people okay get up
to 84 off USPS and UPS rates and if
that's not enough use my call promo code
to try shipstation for free for two
months okay and the promo code is Tim
Dillon Tim d-i-l-l-o-n over 130 000
companies have grown their e-commerce
businesses with ship station 98 of
companies that stick with ship station
for a year become customers for life so
use promo code Tim Dillon at
shipstation.com for your free 60-day
trial that's Tim
d-i-l-l-o-n that
shipstation.com it's no secret that
injuries suck I hate him the pain in the
hospital bills sometimes even missing
days of work it's literally the worst
I've been injured hiring a lawyer could
be the best decision you ever make if
you've been injured if you've been
injured hiring a lawyer it could be the
best decision you ever make a lot of you
think hiring a lawyer is a harder
confusing process but Morgan and Morgan
actually makes it super easy how easy
you ask with Morgan Morgan you could
start a claim from your couch and it
could be about six clicks Sue everybody
um if you don't want to call that's okay
you can simply text back and forth with
your lawyers and the best part of it is
free you only pay if you win your case
Morgan to Morgan America's largest
injury Law Firm has 900 lawyers 100
offices 24 7 customer service staff and
they've recorded over 15 billion dollars
for their clientele all you have to do
is dial pound law or go to the
people.com10 that's dial pound law or
forthepeople.com Jim that's dial pound
law or forthepeople.com Tim this is a
paid advertisement Credit Suisse CFO
teams to hold talks this week on
scenarios for Bank this is never good
when you have a weekend meeting with
people that are asking for the scenarios
credit Swiss will be holding meetings
over the weekend to assess scenarios for
the bank as it struggles to regain
Confidence from the market
people with knowledge of the matter say
and what this basically means is that
you have uh you know the CFO and people
like that and the CEO and they're going
through the numbers and they're trying
to formulate scenarios that mean that
may reshape the future of the bank and
they're not commenting on that of course
but this looks a little similar to when
people have been tweeting and writing
about this that's what happened to
Lehman Brothers as well now
we have as a country and I want you to
think about this over the last year
because this has been the policy of the
United States of America the policy of
this country as I've talked about
um has been
um basically a National Suicide with
regard to the unwavering support of the
Ukraine billions and billions hundreds
of billions of dollars to the Ukraine
doing nothing but increasing the resolve
in in terms of Russia with their uh
willing to do to win the war pushing
Russia and China closer together okay
trying to sanction Russia Russia then
going [__] you we're just going to sell
natural gas to other places like India
ending up being kind of financially okay
with regard to how Russia operates you
know the Russians that the economy is
much obviously much smaller than the
United States but they were able to be
they were pretty pretty quickly were
able to shore up their economy even
after these sanctions which did not have
the devastating blow and impact that we
thought we are now in a position where
we pollen is sending uh uh fighter jets
to the Ukraine we have a much wider War
potentially going to happen right now uh
that the United States is not only
engineering it is supporting and it this
is probably something we either want to
happen or God are the people running
this country stupid uh not thinking it
would happen I'm voting for the former
this is something we actually want to
see happen you also now have what looks
pretty much like an economic collapse or
the best case of fed correction but
really what an economic collapse at home
because we are not you know minding the
store we had artificially low interest
rates for well over a decade for the
longest period really in American
history we enabled bubbles everywhere in
real estate and Tech and everything and
now those chickens are coming home to
roost uh there's Bank runs 550 million
people have withdrawn money out of banks
um these bubbles are bursting the tech
bubble which you know has been the
bubble that is probably the most obvious
the most reported on is now bursting in
front of your eyes which is why you know
Silicon Valley Bank which is the startup
bank is collapse it's now in you know
custody of the feds and now we have
other problems credit Swiss
um First National Bank
this could be very very ugly all the
while we are continuing to write checks
to support a war in the Ukraine between
uh a regional conflict between this you
know Russia and the Ukraine which
started out over a few regions in in the
the dunbas area I think it's Northern
Ukraine I don't know and now uh with the
rhetoric of the Ukrainian leader has
become a all-out fight who's going to
win Russia or Ukraine which regime will
get toppled first in the United States
of America is participating in that we
could not be in a worse position
globally right now we have Russia and
China kind of working together
we have our economic power the thing
that we pride ourselves on we're we are
going to be seeing a massive reduction
right now in our economy a huge
contraction best case obviously
um and it's not like 2008 the FED can't
do what it did then it cannot Infuse
Capital the way it did it cannot go save
the banks it cannot save the entire
Financial system we have spent years and
years and years creating this problem
everybody people that are a lot smarter
than me people who understand this in in
depth in the way that I do not have been
warning that this day will come and it
feels like this day is coming I hope
that's not the case and I only ask you
to not kill me if you see me in the
street
um I'll give you the glasses don't kill
me they're you know they're nice you got
to keep cleaning them over and over and
over to get a spray with the whole thing
but I'm just saying that
we have a president who's has dementia
he's in the cognitive decline he's not
running the show the show is this is to
anyone this is not political about it
it's not a political idea I'm not like
well is it there it's it's obvious to
anyone that Joe Biden is barely
cognizant like you know Joe Biden's
family you know I would talk about this
on the patreon but Joe Biden's family
like had some meeting in Nantucket
deciding whether he was going to run
again and they all came to the
conclusion that was a good idea that he
ran again it's like what questions were
asked at the meeting at the family
meeting like what topics of discussion
were there to ascertain that Biden was
good to run again like that's a little
wild to me the idea that they're like
well pop seems good
good
I mean he's falling he's drooling he
doesn't really know where he is or what
he's doing but I think it seems like he
we could so he's kind of you know
they're stuffing him they're bringing
him out they're giving him the best
drugs uh I guess to just get him through
these things
but uh you know because he is the he's
the system right he's the face of of of
the way that we've been running this
system forever for hundreds of years Joe
Biden is not the face of it and what an
appropriate face
could there be more of an appropriate
phrase that hollowed out gargoyle face
of someone who knows where the bodies
are buried which is why he was elected
and is basically trying to put a face on
American Military uh policy militarism
American Empire building and financial
um you know the dominance of uh large
corporations in America uh as the
Arbiters of national policy that is what
Joe Biden was elected to do and then
give you a little you know dangle little
things like oh here's a year off
Community College and all these things
it may and oh we have look it's a trans
Batman all these things that make you
think there's actual progress happening
but what he really is elected to do is
doing what he he does right he's a
symbol of national death and then it's
not that he's horrible either I mean
there could have been a lot worse right
you they could have elected you know
worse people maybe at this stage of our
Empire's decline having a dead president
is better than having a live one I don't
know that's a fair debate but what
you're seeing now is you're seeing you
know
the real rubber meets the road
reality of that our lifestyles and this
is you know was said by Russ Baker on
the show he goes they've been
artificially subsidized for a very long
time
the things that we take for granted the
way that we live the homes that we live
in the gas we put in our cars the credit
that we charge all of the things that we
need all of these things we never really
think about them we always know that
someone somewhere bails us out there's
always somebody that bails the system
out there is always somebody that comes
from up above some Illuminati meeting
some [__] a group of people chanting
in the woods figures it out there's
always somebody above us there's an
adult there's Mommy and Daddy and yes
they're the luciferian elite but they
kind of always come through at the end
and they keep the Chick-fil-A pumping
and that's all we really think about we
think about at the end of the day
somebody always comes from some dark
crevice or corner from some smoke-filled
room uh from some dark I don't know a
basement seller of a mansion in Newport
Rhode Island some you know humanoid
figure uh comes out and saves the day
there's always some backroom deal made
that bails us out and it's all it's
really our it's a prayer that that
happens now if it doesn't happen now I
don't know what will happen I don't know
what will happen
um the thing that we have going for us
is a massive military
that's what the dollar is backed up by
right the power of the gun so we do have
a massive military
there's that
but there's not too much else going for
us and that's a little scary and I don't
know how many backroom deals are going
to save us uh right now it is it is
something where even the menial
understanding that I have of these
things is that they are very bad and
they are not good
um that's the you know that's the Kamala
Harris explanation Russia is a bigger
country that invaded Ukraine which is a
smaller country so I'll do the Kamala
Harris explanation Banks when they have
money are good Banks without money are
bad but that's why they explain things
to you like three-year-olds because they
think you are a three-year-old I mean
that's really what we've we've seen I
mean this is idiocracy in real time
we've seen uh the things you're supposed
to swallow and accept get increasingly
ridiculous over time increasingly
ridiculous over time so we're at a point
now where the reason that you've been
able to get people to accept all this
gobbledygook is because you can still
put food in their faces and they can
still turn on their air conditioner and
things haven't completely collapsed they
have in other parts of the country that
we ignore but now it might be coming for
all of us so the hope is that somewhere
some reptile figure something out this
is uh you know this is time to uh
basically hope that this is not a
massive uh failure of all the banks this
is not going to look good
because it doesn't turn into a glorious
Marxist Revolution what it just turns
into is a lot of fat people in the
street sitting down
there's going to be a lot of fat people
sitting in the street it's not going to
look good there's going to be a lot of
large overweight people
sitting in the street and gonna have to
walk around them and walk over them and
it's going to be very very difficult
you know it's basically it's like a line
it a ride for Disney World but
everybody's given up because they're
like we don't even know what's happening
is it broken
the fat people yell as they sit on the
line is it broken
it is it is broken
Sam Hyde tweeted something or retweeted
something that was really funny about
um that America was a carnival
uh people are in America are now
becoming aware that they are uh on a
carnival ride or on a Carnival that is
closing down and it was just these
people like throwing things in like a
Walmart or something but that is kind of
analogous to what it you know does feel
like a little bit it's like we've gone
on all the rides but now it is kind of
it is closing down
um you know and and listen I I'm only
asking for I am only asking for your uh
patience because
whatever happens there's going to be
there's going to be we can here's the
good thing about our food supply it's
chemicals
this is a good thing the good thing
about our food supply is it's chemicals
it's not going anywhere those same
chemicals that spilled all over those
people's yards in Palestine Ohio where's
that in the news by the way and I'm
still trying to do the [__] benefit
show it's hard to get avails from
theaters around there relax I'm gonna do
it with Matt Rife
who's who's the hot comedian with the
six pack it's gonna be weird it's gonna
be like two guys on stage they're the
same person and half of the audience
will be his fans which is like hot
checks and half the audience will be my
fans Jan six but the point is what we're
doing is we're we're trying to figure
that out but the same chemicals that are
in those spills are used at the Olive
Garden
the good it's yellow garden it's the
same chemicals there's no difference the
good news is you've been eating
chemicals for your entire life
in Europe people will die if they if
someone from Europe at the Olive Garden
they would drop dead in the parking lot
they would go because your body wouldn't
be able to handle it but you have been
acclimated to chemicals your entire life
so when we have to eat chemicals sludge
because that's the only thing left your
system will go
tastes like a tour of Italy to me
so that's a good thing here's another
great thing we have a lot of space in
America nobody talks about this we have
acres and acres and acres and acres of
land there's a lot of [__] land
there's more than enough land for
everybody to set up their own tiny house
live out of a van whatever there's a lot
of land it's a lot of land not great
land because the rich have taken all of
that you know the coast and the waters
and the rivers
there's not a lot of that but there's a
lot of flat hot
Dusty land that is land that you can
live on this isn't Panic Time by any
stretch if you don't mind living in a
car living by your wits
you know getting a weapon uh learning
how to skin a deer watched Rogan they'll
tell you about the back strap how to do
it uh this is not a bad time this is an
invigorating time I think it's an
exciting time for people this is a time
where I think people are gonna actually
start to connect with who they really
are as people they go well I don't wanna
walk into that office don't like your
job good news you don't have one anymore
like to commute to work great news
there's no work to commute to get a tiny
house or a van live on the side of the
highway there's a lot of land
this is why this crazy [__] Marianne
Williamson who's uh was just by the way
who I love and I'm gonna support
I don't know if she'll ever be my new
Lori there'll never be another Lorry
June 9 Chicago Theater 101 comedy.com
we'll celebrate the Life and Legacy of
um the great Lori Lightfoot The Life and
Legacy of Lori Lightfoot celebrated June
9 Chicago Theater but Marianne
Williamson is now being accused she's
now being accused of abusive Behavior to
staff or something like that which makes
them maybe I'll supporter it's turning
into a definite and I don't know what
um people don't understand about these
Crystal [__] I'm gonna call them have
you ever met these Crystal [__] the
crystal [__] will fly off the handle
like no one else
people that are Zen and go it's all just
and Marianne Williams has got that Twang
and she goes the Health Care system in
America and it is not there is a
difference between health insurance and
health care and Healthcare you know and
and when she is you know she has that
nice soft voice and she's just trying to
tell you about life because life is
about energy and energy is is all around
us at all times and it's a choice it's
making a choice and I'm a narcissist I
think only in myself every minute of the
day but I actually talk about others but
when I'm talking about other people I'm
thinking only myself and my energy and
how I'm feeling and what I need to do
and other people are actually just ideas
to me that's me I'm Marianne Williamson
and and these and by the way that
doesn't mean she can't do some good [__]
if she gets in there because a lot of
people do good stuff by accident most of
them but Marianne Williamson's a crystal
[__] and these Crystal [__] fly off
the [__] handle you know people say
it would be foaming spitting
uncontrollable rage said a former
staffer who like most people that spoke
with Politico was granted Adam and
anonymity because of their concerns
about being sued for breaking
non-disclosure agreements it was
traumatic and the experience in the end
was terrifying because here's what makes
Marion Williamson terrifying the rage is
unexpected when you work from you know
if you work for Chris Christie a big fat
guy you know he's gonna blow up he's
going to blow up blood sugar is low can
I pay a [__] but when you work for
Marion Williams it all starts like this
it starts like this we can do real good
things together we can do real good
thing now did you get did you get me my
coffee
you did okay it's a little cold now
it's look this cough is a little cold it
no it's a little cold the car that's all
no it's not a big deal
you know the real problem in this
country is you know people are living in
food deserts and they don't have access
to you know high quality vegan meals you
know what I got to be honest this coffee
is kind of bothering me a little more
than I thought it would be but it it's
it's fine I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
make are you Mexican by any chance I
love that I spent time in Santa Fe uh
there was a writer's Retreat I was a
writer I am a writer I am a writer I
wrote all of my I don't do ghost writers
the people will tell you I actually
wrote all of my books
um and I was in Santa Fe we did a
writer's Retreat and uh the Mexicans
were actually because so much of what we
eat here that's Mexican food is very
unhealthy but that's not what they eat
Mexico they eat a lot of braises and
meats and stews and there's actually a
lot of vegetables and uh I I learned
that it's like I'm drinking iced coffee
actually it's really it feels like I'm
I'm drinking ice here which is not what
I'm trying to do I'm trying to warn my
soul but anyway in Santa Fe at the
writer's Retreat I'm a writer I I was
sitting there
and these lovely abuelas is that what
you call them these abuelas these
Mexican grandmothers oh man they might
have been uh 80 90 150 years old I don't
know but these Abuelos would come in
every day with these blankets now I
swear they'd knit these blankets
overnight and they'd knit them with the
spirit of their people it was beautiful
and they would come in and you know
every now and then they would swaddle me
like a child and put me to sleep and the
the thing about when the cough is cold
the thing about it is it hurts my throat
and my throat gets cold that's the thing
that's the only problem that's the only
problem honey so what I'm saying is and
do you have an abuela oh she's she's
passed on into the other realm well I
mean
peace to her but these are boilers would
they would they would they would they
would swaddle me and they would just
they would tell me the tales of the that
they would tell the Mexican children and
I just and from that it was just such a
beautiful moment of transference of
energy from one abuela to a young writer
in Santa Fe New Mexico at a retreat did
I did I ask for a lemon bar I think I I
did am I losing my mind am I losing my
mind or did I ask for a lemon bar okay
because we're trying to change the world
here we're trying to change the [__]
world okay and I'm telling you right now
for the love of God if you [__] with me
here and I'm just trying to put it I'm a
little late on the line I'm just gonna
lay it online my goal is to help other
people but if you [__] with me here I
swear to God I swear to God I'll come
back and I'll kill you from every life
I'll kill you from every [__]
lifetime that I've ever lived I'm
drinking icy [__] coffee I'm the only
person in America that went to the
writer's retreat in Santa Fe and was
swaddled by old Mexican abuelas so that
I could come here and communicate the
truth from their ancient people and I'm
telling you right now I shouldn't be
drinking cold coffee without a [__]
lemon bar I'm just saying honey I'm not
trying to fly off the handle I'm not
trying to fly are you gay my first
husband was gay and that was fine I knew
that when I married him it didn't matter
because I believe in energy and energy
is the purest form of love and it didn't
matter to me that he had sex with man
that didn't really bother me what
bothered me was the lying isn't it
always lying that bothers you that's
what bothered me I would tell him I
would say listen to me Christopher kind
of a gay name Christopher I'd say
Christopher I know everything you're
doing and with everybody and that's fine
with me I just don't need you lying
about it I don't need you lying about it
and it's just like you know it's one of
those things in life and you know we're
great friends to this day I mean we we
of course have the restraining order he
has one on me so I cannot see him in the
physical person but we are always
communicating through our dreams and um
I'm just telling you this I'm just
telling you right this right now if
there's ever cold coffee on this [__]
desk again I'm gonna [__] murder you
you understand I'm going to kill you and
then I will kill you as many times as I
can I will chase you through these lives
because we get many lifetimes but here's
the thing in every lifetime I've been a
self-important [__] and I will always be
a self-important white woman and a con
always you understand that [__] dummy
you understand that you dumb [__] you're
poor as [__] that's why you can't eat
good food like I do you poor fat [__]
America is a bunch of poor fat [__]
because they can't eat stars like I do I
eat the [__] Milky Way and the Galaxy
not that [__] bar I eat raw energy
[__]
I eat agave syrup and I put it in my
that's what I do I own a farm of agave
cactuses and I rub my [__] with them the
spiky ones that's what I do and then I
offer the blood as the sacrifice to Odin
if you ever [__] with my coffee again
I'll rip your [__] throat out I'll
rip your [__] throat out you dirty
[__] do you understand me you dirty
dirty dirty wet back [__] get my [__]
coffee right or I'll kill you
but that's what happens to people uh
like Marion Williamson because again
they are in a different vibrational
plane they don't need
um a lot of the things that we need
um they are fed um by energy and and uh
but she's our favorite I hope she sticks
with this I hope she doesn't leave I
want to see her flip out more because
you got to remember when you're a
crystal [__]
everything's about you
everything's about you right so whenever
that Apple card is upset even the
slightest bit
a real nightmare but
always we thank everybody for listening
Tim dilloncomedy.com we have
um live shows on sale in really cool
places Chicago and San Francisco two of
my favorite markets to do comedy were
also in Portland Tacoma North Charleston
Hershey PA Chicago Illinois Milwaukee
Wisconsin ending in San Francisco and
they were kind of taking off the summer
to just podcast it is my sincere hope
that we are not in an insane crisis uh
financial crisis but if it is I've
already pleaded with you spare my life
I'll show you where the others are I I
will find I will I get the I'm friends
with the chefs we'll put the gun to the
chef we'll make them make all the good
food for us please I'm with you
please
but behave
behave if it gets bad because there's
going to be a can of pasta and a bag of
cake cake em that's for the kids and for
you and there will be coffee and there
will be drugs and there will be Netflix
so don't worry about it there's nothing
better than eating a can of pasta and
and watching [__] uh uh Outer Banks
how about that
you eat a little bag of cake and you
watch a little Wednesday
and go what's the difference between
this and Harry Potter and you go oh shut
up who cares the country's collapsed
doesn't really matter
uh timle comedy.com and now we have an
interview with an Insider at Silicon
Valley Bank who's calling us anonymously
here we go listen to music and podcasts
and we know you do
raycon is premium audio at the perfect
price point so you can build great
habits without breaking the bank whether
you're looking for a pair of everyday
earbuds low latency gaming headphones or
speaker with a battery that will last
all night at your next party raycon's
got you covered and yep raycon started
half the price of other premium audio
Brands so you don't have to ever choose
between products you can get one of each
or a pair and a spare and still pay less
than you would with some of the other
guys I love Ray Conn's I'm telling you
right now
listen even if you know you love raycons
as much as I do raycon wants to make
sure you feel great about your purchase
they offer buy now pay later options
every purchase has an easy and free
return guarantee please provide a
personal oh
I love raycon three customizable sound
profiles earbud tap functions noise
isolation awareness mode custom gel tips
for the perfect most comfortable in-ear
fit Crystal Clear call Quality Water and
sweat resistance I'm telling you right
now it's great to have these things even
if you have the other earbuds you'll
lose them get these two call to action
ready to buy something small with a big
impact go to buy raycon.com Tim today to
get 15 off your raycon order that's buy
raycon.com to score 15 off buy
ratecon.com Tim dude it's so stressful
buying tickets I'm telling you right now
I was trying to go to the Taylor Swift
concert with a good friend of mine and I
said to her get us the tickets and she
couldn't and she took her own life
buying tickets to your favorite event
shouldn't be stressful game time is the
fastest and easiest way to buy tickets
for the sports music comedy and theaters
nears you with killer deals on last
minute tickets their best pricing
guarantee you can stop stressing over
the tickets and start getting hyped for
the fun you're gonna have I'm telling
you right now I mean there's all kinds
of events that are happening that are
very exciting for me
um and listen forget planning months in
advance game time has deals on tickets
right now up until the day of the event
get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater more I mean the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price if you find tickets in the
same section in row for Less game time
will credit you a hundred and ten
dollars for the difference the Nicki
Minaj concert I want to go see
from this and the other festivals with
all the other people on them
it's gonna be big
can images if you see before you buy us
you know exactly what to expect when you
arrive snag the tickets without the
stress if Game Time download the game
time app create an account use it Go Tim
for 20 off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account a redeem
code Tim for 20 off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed all right we have an
anonymous Insider now from Silicon
Valley Bank and we appreciate you
calling us we're gonna keep your uh
identity secret because I think to my
understanding you still may be working
there
um but we do we checked you out and you
are legit and we do appreciate you
calling
um are you still working in the bank in
in in any capacity or what what's going
on yeah so we're being what used to be
Silicon Valley Bank is being run by the
FED at the moment um they actually
disappointed their own CEO the other day
from
a great guy I forgot his last name pop
it off with us or something like that
but um
the old company that used to be SBB I
think it's called svb Financial had just
filed for bankruptcy today so
um they're a different entity than we
are right now I think at the moment
we're called Silicon Valley Bridge
something or the other but yeah we're
being run by this bed at the moment so I
think that makes me a government
employee all right well congrats yeah
um and there people are saying and I
know this is maybe outside of your range
of expertise people are positing that
you know you had Signature Bank collapse
Silicon Valley Bank people are now
saying Credit Suisse obviously getting
an infusion I believe 52 billion dollars
from a a Central Bank in in maybe
Switzerland if I recall
um that's correct that's correct right
people are still saying they're bringing
up the Lehman Brothers situation where
they also had you could kind of this
restructuring going on over the weekend
looking at different scenarios for the
bank and that it still collapsed you
know noriel rabini has said like a you
know a a rate hike uh European Central
Bank I believe rate high could by even
half a basis point might collapse the
bank and then you might also see um uh
you know just kind of this like Black
Monday like you had in 2008 with Lehman
Brothers uh I'm you know but obviously
being credit Swiss
um and then
um a First National Bank taking a bunch
of other small retail banks with a
credit Swiss being about a trillion but
of course you know Untold more money as
well and then you know I believe it's is
it Signature Bank that's all I'm sorry
it's First National right it's also
the First Republic Bank First Republic
yeah
so First Republic
um
and they have you know maybe 10 or 12
smaller Regional Banks is it your
estimation it could get that bad Monday
or you don't know
I'm not here to you know like Doom and
Gloom but it definitely seems like uh
what you know everything that the FED is
trying to do at the moment seems to not
be working the way that they intended it
and you know banks are now banks that
were you know like First Republic Bank
is a bank that is run well it's a great
institution
um and they're failing mass of a bank
run you know it's nothing no fault of
their own so it definitely seems like
um they just don't want to it seems like
they're trying to like just avoid
bailing out the entire system all
together but it seems that it's leading
that way like you know like you said
this isn't exactly my area of expertise
but um you know the feeling that I get
is that everyone is just on edge things
are changing hour by hour so
um you know I've just been constantly on
standby this entire week just waiting to
see you know what next little bit of
news that we get so how did how did
Silicon Valley Bank is a bank run
as well right this is why Silicon Valley
Bank failed is this something initially
oh yeah I you know um
oh I forgot the exact wordings for it
but yeah it was you know the initial
problems are caused by a bank run you
know all these Silicon Valley Tech
companies keep like large amounts of
cash with us and you know on our
financial dealings spook them and they
all just started taking their money out
of of the banks so yeah that's what you
know started all this back on you know
last Thursday and is this people are
blaming kind of Peter Thiel for this is
this something that you do you put any
Credence in that like the idea that he
was kind of running around telling
people they're insolvent and taking all
his money out yeah um you know from what
I've been told Silicon Valley Bank was
in Sullivan back in September
um and it just seems like they were just
avoiding offloading all you know that
dead Capital that they had and you know
when they you know when they finally did
that you know that's when the bank runs
started to happen but um it's
you know I it's all you know this it it
was an unfortunate situation just
because you know in the Senior
Management at Silicon Valley made some
really horrible risky decisions and kind
of ran their entire company into the
ground and you know sold off all their
stock you know in the process of it so
tell me what risky decisions you think
they made that ran as you said the
company into the ground
well I mean for as small of a bank you
know sap isn't exactly like a you know
it's not a small financial institution
but it's not a large one either and
during the pandemic things were going
great for us we were expanding at a rate
that seemed
you know of unsustainable honestly for
uh for a bank of our size and you know
as soon as the the economy started you
know going south a little bit that we
were making layoffs and it just it
seemed like the decisions that were
being made by our Executives they
thought things were going to be you know
great forever interest rates are going
to be low forever and then I've seen as
they started to increase we were put in
a very bad situation almost immediately
what kind of place was it like to work
um it was you know
it was a very you know inclusive like
work environment you know it was it's a
very hard place to get fired from you
know what I mean well um that's gonna
change
that's about to change huh yeah that's
uh but no it was um you know they
compensate their employees very well you
know that was the whole big thing a news
story as well everyone in the company
was getting their bonuses exactly at the
time that the company
um used to exist more or less so
they treat their employees really well
you know we have very nice offices and
it's they definitely make you feel it's
like you know diversity and inclusion
and all that kind of stuff so um well
well that's lovely but that that clearly
didn't stop the nightmarish collapse no
yeah exactly it's um all the did they
focus too much on that with the
diversity and the inclusion stuff like
that
yeah I wouldn't say that that's clearly
not the reason that the bank of course
it's not the reason it fell but like but
you know it was I would definitely say
it was more Progressive than your
average bank is but um you know not
overly so no I didn't feel like it was
okay
um and and right now it's in the custody
of the feds they're running the bank and
they they went to look for a buyer and
they couldn't find one
yeah I you know there are a bunch of
names floated out like um the Saudi
Arabian Sovereign funder they love
diversity and inclusion the Saudi
Arabian Sovereign fund that's what I've
heard yeah that's really I'm sure they
got really excited when they go hey we
have a awoke failing Bank of non-binary
people you want to come and get involved
with this and the Saudis were like of
course why wouldn't we
by the way the Saudis might be what's
needed at Silicon Valley Bank they might
whip it into shape they might come in
Muhammad MBS so wait a minute why is
nobody buying this Bank in your
estimation why do you think it's so
unattractive
two people is it is it like the balance
sheet is is it just a mess in there if
I'm buying this thing is it like buying
a house that's been foreclosed on and
not taken care of
it seems like this new CEO that the FED
appointed is trying to unwind all that
mess at the moment so I think they're
just trying to put the company in a
position where it would be a more
attractive
entity to buy um you know and I also
think they're looking for the right
buyer as well with you know Silicon
Valley Bank has a 50 market share with
banking with Dunkey capitalists and they
don't want that to be
something that some foreign conglomerate
you know can control or you know get
their hands I think they want to make
sure that whoever buys this company in
the future has you know and you know of
their best interests at heart too I
guess because we don't want to give
control over
I guess a lot of potential new American
companies to a sovereign wealth fund
yeah it's I mean it's really the only
thing Americans got going as far as the
Innovation part so yeah we don't really
want to Outsource that so the highest
later I guess right right well I mean it
it certainly seems like the Golden Era
of tech is over that's in every article
that you read now people are saying uh
that's done and that you know you're
you're this is kind of maybe The New
Normal of you know is that something
that you are getting used to as a person
I don't know if you work more in the the
banking sector or if you're
you know in in you know
fintech or whatever you're in but like
what are you preparing for a life
you know kind of very much like the when
the manufacturing jobs went overseas and
many of those people had to live
horrible lives in the middle of the
country and became addicted to opioids
do you are you preparing are you and
your friends preparing for that
oh you know it definitely seems like you
know things can't be you know it can't
be the Golden Age forever so it
definitely had to unlock an event really
I think it's happening a little bit
faster than most people expected it to
um and you know these are all you know
like silvergate and svb these are all
companies that were doing business with
fbx and in the cryptocurrency as well do
you do you think crypto hastened this
collapse the financial system getting in
bed with crypto that hasteness
um it it didn't help all right for sure
it definitely didn't why did financial
institutions get so involved with such a
speculative asset now obviously we could
ask this question with subprime
mortgages but in crypto when you like if
you explain cryptocurrency right to
um a you know McDonald's employee that
got to the country a month ago on a raft
they would maybe tell you they didn't
feel safe investing in it why did the
CEOs of these Banks who went to Ivy
League institutions uh get in bed with
this stuff
oh but you know it's it's tough to tell
if they were you know they fell for the
same bit that everybody else fell for or
if they knew and just felt like they
could make some money in the short term
off of it um so it was probably money it
was greed it was the idea that it was
anything I think it always comes out in
agreed with especially when you get up
to those like people that work in like
the higher equivalent of the industry um
they definitely see
you know an opportunity to make you know
maybe they don't
you know you you figure they are smart
people so they might not have fallen for
the whole like FTX like Rifts but they
definitely saw an opportunity to you
know increase their personal wealth I
mean no that's a little yeah I'm not an
expert on cryptocurrency by any means
what do you can you talk about what you
did at the bank
he's on the secure I was a security I
just did I.T what can you talk a little
bit about what you did
yeah I work in like the the payments
Department doing like operations as an
analyst Okay so
it's more on uh you know where all the
people that do what people were talking
about you know on Thursday and Friday
when people were trying to take all
their money out of them you have a
horrible connection is there any where
you can go to get a little bit of a
better connection on your phone is is
Silicon Valley Bank shutting off the
phones
I don't know I got it yeah I mean can
you hear me better now yes okay
um sorry I forgot what you're talking
about
um the failure of your bank destroying
the economy
um no uh we were talking about what you
did for the bank you said you worked in
operations yeah so yeah right now it's a
difficult time in operation just because
as we get back online we're trying to
sort out
what clients still need the money that
they sent requests for is last week um
you know who took their business
elsewhere uh what needs to be redone and
what you know it's
in operations it involves like foreign
currency as well so we need to like
re-establish connections with all the
foreign banks that we used to work with
that refuse to work with us last week so
um it's been a whole process trying to
like get that system back online and you
know based on what I've been told it
should be better next week but um you
know like I said things change hour by
hour so I really don't know what to
expect what do you think the future is
of Silicon Valley Banks does it have any
shot
um you know from what I've been told by
our new CEO the plan at the moment is to
run SCB as a company like it normally
was until they you know find a potential
buyer so I think that's the direction
they would like ahead you know run it
get it back on its feet make it look
like you know something you would
actually want to buy and then just you
know try it out so now has it explained
the bailout it has been bailed out
it
it has yeah I mean it it has been bailed
out at this point it's being run by the
government and all the people you know
all the deposits are fully 100 back
actually I saw an advertising for SUV
the other day saying it's the safest
place to deposit your money so yeah not
on my show this is what they're trying
to suck out right now yeah the safest
place to keep your money is athletic
greens
it's not svb well listen we appreciate
taking the time to fill us in I think to
like
um this is obviously something that's
changing hour by hour as you said and
you know people are really thinking
about Monday as like a a real you know
like Black Monday situation but maybe
that's not true hopefully it's not true
um yeah I'd still like to have a job I
mean I
what do you live up in the Bay Area
oh no I live in uh like Paradise Valley
in uh Phoenix
okay I knew what would you want for svb
from Phoenix
oh yeah oh yeah so we have uh yeah one
of the biggest offices is located in
Tempe actually I think the biggest I
think the office is located okay
well listen we wish you well we hope
that you you know figure out
you know a new career for yourself when
this comes down do you have any other
skills
um no I don't but you know they
financial institutions love hiring white
men with like under you know that really
don't have any skills besides like
Microsoft you know proficiency so I
think I'll be fine did you go to a good
school
um yeah I yeah I think I can't really
it was a really small uh School uh like
a small business school so I think that
yeah I'd rather not say like Wharton
no no it wasn't that nice
right okay I'm not I'm no genius we we
believe you
[Music]
um well thank you so much for calling in
and we we really appreciate it we'll
keep your identity
secret and um we hope everything works
out at svb but let me tell you what will
I believe happened to many of you people
you will move to the middle of the
country you'll become addicted to drugs
uh there will be generations of your
families that will be destroyed you will
be met with uh uh complete and other
um contempt uh from the public but
really apathy apathy is the main thing
that you will deal with because people
will not care about your communities we
will dump
um uh chemical spills
there and we will not care
um you will end up 10 to 15 years from
now smoking cigarettes out of a
Narcotics Anonymous meeting before a
relapse at a small biker bar on the
outskirts of town this is what will
happen uh and deservedly so to everybody
in Tech or that has aided or abetted
that in any way that I'm not saying this
is good or bad or I'm not calling for
this to happen I'm telling you what will
happen this is uh from history this will
happen you will eat at grocery stores
where the meat isn't good and there will
be mold on even the frozen chicken that
you will try to serve to your family
um it will be very difficult for you to
hold on this is a hellscape that you
will inherit but until that time
um and even during that time you know
the Tim Dillon show does nothing but
wish you well
thank you